The Book of Boba Fett Fett has finally
come to a close, as the famous bounty
hunter rallies his forces for battle against
the Pyke Syndicate and its enforcer, Cad Bane.
The series goes in some interesting directions in
Chapter 5 and Chapter 6, which heavily focus on
the Mandalorian Din Djarin, the Yoda lookalike
Grogu, and the legendary Luke Skywalker.
But the finale brings everything back to Tatooine
as Boba's battle with the Pykes escalates into an
all-out war across Mos Espa. Does the finale have
ramifications for the wider Star Wars universe?
More importantly, does it tease what's coming up
ahead in The Mandalorian Season 3? Well, sort of.
"For now?"
"We wait."
The tension on Tatooine cranks up from the very
beginning of the final season 1 episode, as Boba,
Fennec Shand, and the Mandalorian survey the
Sanctuary wreckage — R.I.P. Garsa Fwip. Boba also
faces an emotional blow as Bane reveals that the
Pykes are actually the ones who killed the Tusken
tribe, not the Nikto Sand Riders. The massacre
is revenge for their attack on the Spice train.
All of this only hardens Boba's determination to
rid Tatooine of the Syndicate once and for all.
But when the battle for Mos Espa
gets started, writer Jon Favreau
and director Robert Rodriguez deliver a
pulse-pounding fight for the very soul
of Tatooine. Luckily, Boba, Din, and
Fennec aren't alone in their struggle.
The big cliffhanger at the end of Chapter 6
sees Luke Skywalker offer Grogu a choice — he
can either take the Beskar chainmail and return to
Din Djarin, or he can pick Yoda's old lightsaber
and train to become a fully-fledged Jedi. On one
hand, it would be great to see him train in the
Force and master his abilities, but we all know
that he really belongs with his surrogate father.
Thankfully, Favreau gives fans what they want as
R2-D2 lands Luke's X-wing in Peli Motto's hangar,
with Grogu sitting comfortably in the pilot's
seat. Because Grogu's memory is clouded,
he doesn't have many meaningful connections — and
although Luke and Ahsoka Tano are kind to him,
he's got a much closer bond with Din.
At least his brief time with Luke means he already
has a better grip on his Force abilities than he
did before, which is quite useful when the streets
of Mos Espa erupt into a deadly firefight when the
other gangs of the city betray their treaty with
Boba, attacking Boba's enforcers. It's not exactly
surprising, since the different factions are
clearly just out for money rather than respect.
Although, things start to look dire when
the hordes of Pykes deploy two deadly
Scorpenek droids. Oh dear. Nevertheless,
Boba has some other backup to rely on.
The devastating power of the Scorpenek
droids causes chaos in the battle because
their shields are too strong for Boba's
army to blast through with any of their
weapons. Din Djarin even whips out the Darksaber
to try to penetrate the shields, but it has no
effect at all — although he probably needs some
more training to carry its weight. But then,
the finale pays off on Chapter 3's promise as
Boba finally rides his Rancor into battle. The
monster's power quickly overwhelms the first
Scorpenek droid, with a little help from Grogu.
Luke's training comes in handy
for the little green Force-user,
as he yanks a key component from the
droid's parts that makes it vulnerable.
Grogu clearly has a fondness for shiny metal
objects, because it's pretty reminiscent
of the way he grabs that ball from the
Razor Crest in The Mandalorian Season 1.
After the Rancor finishes the first droid off,
Boba steers it to the second, quickly eviscerating
it. The destruction of the droids and the sheer
power of the Rancor sends the Pykes running,
which is a nice piece of symbolism: Tatooine
is taking itself back from its oppressors.
Although, it's not over just yet, as Cad Bane
shows his face again to try to kill Boba.
Cad Bane's arrival at the end of Chapter 6 calls
back to the Western genre which George Lucas was
originally inspired by when creating Star Wars
back in the 70s. Director Robert Rodriguez leans
into the gunslinging genre once again for Boba
Fett's duel with Bane in the finale, as they trade
insults in a tense standoff. Bane even points
out that they've known each other a long time,
calling back to the times they crossed
paths during The Clone Wars animated series.
Bane makes it clear that he might be an old
man, but he's still quicker than Boba when it
comes to a quickdraw gunfight. For a minute,
it even looks like Bane might kill Boba.
"Look out for yourself.
Everything else is weakness."
But this is Boba Fett, so he doesn't go down
that easily. Instead, he uses his gaffi stick
to swiftly knock Bane to the ground — symbolizing
how his new strength comes from having a family.
He even avenges his fallen Tusken tribe
by killing Bane with the stick... Sure,
he's a fan-favorite villain, but his
death has been a long time coming.
Cad Bane's death causes the few remaining Pykes
to retreat — let's face it, if he can't take Boba
Fett down, who can? So, it looks like this is a
new era for Tatooine now that the crime lord has
liberated the planet from the Pyke Syndicate.
Fennec Shand even wipes out that gang's last
foothold on the planet by killing their leader and
executing Mayor Mok Shaiz [MOCK SHAYZ]. Leaving
either of them alive would mean that the
Spice trade on Tatooine could start up again.
Some time after the big battle, Fett reacts
uncomfortably to the Mos Espa residents bowing
and calling him "Lord Boba." He remarks to
Fennec that they're not cut out to rule– a
surprising comment considering everything
they’ve gone through to get here. However,
this is a new role for Fett: murderous Bounty
Hunter turned Local Hero. Fennec responds,
“If not us, then who?”
The finale ends with Din flying his Naboo
Starfighter through space as Grogu sits in
the pod behind him. The little green Force-user
even pesters him to fly at high speeds,
and Din — like any parent — reluctantly obliges.
It's not clear where they're headed, although it's
possible Din wants to redeem himself in the waters
of Mandalore underneath the planet's mines.
Of course, it wouldn't be a Disney+ series
if there wasn't a post-credits scene teasing
the future of the galaxy! The brief scene
takes audiences back to Boba's quarters,
where Cobb Vanth is recuperating
in the gunslinger's bacta tank,
where The Modifier from Chapter 4 is
keeping an eye on him. This clearly
suggests that Vanth is severely wounded
when shot by Cad Bane, but not killed.
It'll be interesting to see how the
modification artist fixes his injuries,
although he's definitely going to need some
new armor to wear instead of just a shirt
and a bandana. Maybe Din Djarin can give him
some spare Beskar in The Mandalorian Season 3.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about The
Book of Boba Fett are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.